Qué papel juega Irán en la Guerra de
Ucrania con el envío según kiev de
drones kamikazes de fabricación iraní
lanzados en las últimas 48 horas por
Rusia contra posiciones civiles
infraestructuras energéticas son muchas
las preguntas por resolver por ahora su
aparente implicación ha llevado a los
funcionarios de kiev a pedir el cese de
las relaciones diplomáticas con la
República islámica
tiene todas las responsabilidades por la
destrucción de las relaciones con
Ucrania teniendo en cuenta las muchas
destrucciones causadas por los drones de
fabricación iraní en la infraestructura
civil de Ucrania la muerte y el
sufrimiento causados a nuestro pueblo y
los nuevos informes de que Irán continúa
suministrando armas a Rusia
imponer sanciones contra Irán por ayudar
a Rusia a matar ucranianos
el ministro de exteriores también instó
al ejecutivo ucraniano a proponer a
Israel la entrega inmediata de sistemas
de defensa aérea y una cooperación de
calidad la implicación de Irán en el
ucraniano era una línea roja para las
autoridades israelíes según la
inteligencia ucraniana Rusia habría
comprado un primer lote de 1750 drones
iraníes y habría más suministros en
camino por su parte tanto Moscú como
Terán continúa negando la procedencia
iraní de los drones
no tenemos esa información se están
utilizando equipos rusos ustedes lo
saben con nombres rusos
[Música]
la República islámica de Irán no está en
ningún lado de la guerra entre Rusia y
Ucrania la República islámica de Irán no
ha exportado ningún arma a ningún bando
de la guerra
Este martes bolodimir celenski dijo que
el 30% de las centrales eléctricas de
Ucrania han sido destruidas generando
apagones masivos por todo el país y es
que la red eléctrica está en el punto de
mira del kremlin como estrategia de cara
al invierno